bonjour Emmanuel le chiffre bonjour à
tous Il me semble qu'on va boire un
petit café dans un instant vous aimez ça
vous les poscafé j'adore ça et bah ça
sert à rien merci Emmanuel je vais très
très bien parce que figurez-vous
qu'aujourd'hui c'est la journée mondiale
de la tortue ah d'accord et donc ça vous
rend heureuse la tortue très bien
est-ce que vous savez combien de temps
met une tortue pour terrestre une tortue
terrestre pour parcourir 250 mètres
signalé dans les eaux de la Dordogne
hier après-midi du côté de Bergerac je
vais vous montrer il a été pêché c'est
véridique il était péché dans les eaux
de la Dordogne hier juste on s'est
simplement rendu compte après la pêche
que c'était un une statue en métal et
pas du tout
la Soto en tout cas n'est pas l'animal
le plus long la femme revient ouvert
vous savez Mimet faire le vert Thomas le
lombric ah bah voilà comme ça le lombric
et aussi le paresseux le paresseux qui
est aussi très lent alors le paresseux
c'est 12 m en 60 minutes vous voyez
Thomas a des vraiment des des qualités
un soupçonnées Thomas
[Rires]
d'après ces mesures l'altération de
l'air dans le métro est en moyenne 5
fois supérieure au seuil maximal
d'exposition prolongée recommandée par
l'OMS au classement des lignes les plus
touchées c'est la 5 qui l'emporte les
causes de cette pollution des systèmes
de freinage et de ventilation parfois
vétustes par ailleurs plus l'air de la
ville est polluée plus les stations le
sont rien qu'en 2022 la France a émis
408 millions de tonnes de CO2 il est
donc
urgent d'agir à un portable
en France oui selon la Cour des comptes
pour sauver le climat il faudrait manger
moins de viande et de produits laitiers
car lors de la digestion les vaches
éructues elles émettent du méthane un
puissant gaz à effet de serre l'élevage
bovin est ainsi responsable de 11,8% des
émissions totales en France je te laisse
ok excusez-moi non c'était Norman norman
Thavaud il a entendu CO2 en fait c'était
pas CE2 au fait
pardon lire que votre activité doit
cesser ou largement diminuer ses vécu
comme une blessure
d'autant que le cheptel a déjà beaucoup
diminué en France 837
000 vaches à viande ou vache laitière en
moins depuis 2016 une baisse de 9,6%.
les Français mangent moins de boeuf en
disant la consommation est passée de 25
kg par personne et par an à 22 kg pour
la Cour des comptes il faut aller plus
loin mais pour atteindre cet objectif
selon ce chercheur le gouvernement doit
inciter les Français à manger moins de
viande 25% des Français dans un récent
sondage disait qu'ils étaient prêt à
tenter l'expérience beaucoup plus qu'en
Italie ou en Pologne où là à l'idée de
déguster des aliments à la poudre
d'insecte ne donne vraiment pas envie à
la population au pays de la pasta on
associe cette nouvelle nourriture
vraiment un danger pour la gastronomie
ouais oui et certains experts ont essayé
de comprendre cette défiance
[Applaudissements]
les abeilles ont même le droit de vote
la somme des messages qu'elle échange
définit une majorité par exemple lorsque
la colonie tout entière doit déménager
chaque abeille argument de sa
proposition de lieu pour installer le
nouveau logis jusqu'à ce qu'une option
commune soit validée par toutes
c'est une fascinante démocratie animale
en entier
nous aimons les lombrics et les vers de
farine
voilà merci de nous avoir suivi en ce
moment bon appétit alors pour moi le
futur je vois bien des repas entiers
dans des petites gélules comme ça genre
tu les mets dans les fesses et bim tu as
tué
en manger par la bouche
à découvrir dans toutes les villes du
monde on compterait plus de rats que
d'habitants
partout ils élimineraient la moitié de
nos ordures
[Musique]
même s'ils sont envahissants voir
gênants ces petits éboueurs méritent une
réputation bien plus équitable
ces énergies
à trouver sa période favori le futur
franchement
là
prenez un abonnement à Tic-Toc soit
épais soit abonnez-vous et oui ils l'ont
fait le duo le plus drôle de France
débarque sur le réseau social chinois
quelques jours seulement après la
création de leur compte les deux
humoristes ressentent déjà plus de
800.000 abonnés et cumu plusieurs
millions de vues sur leur vidéo créez à
l'occasion du Festival de Cannes loup et
sparlière qui dit drame en deux actes à
Cannes on est tous pétriques
contradiction mais peu d'entre nous
vivons une dissonance aussi énorme
carrison Ford à 20h55 si on ne se bouge
pas le cul maintenant on va perdre cette
planète à 20h57 j'ai plusieurs avions
j'adore voler et je dois partir bon
pareil facile de donner des leçons quand
on a passé sa vie à cramer la planète
avec son avion privé dit Teddy bar on a
trouvé la Marion Cotillard américain ça
c'est pas très gentil est-ce que tu
penses qu'on pourrait dire à Harris
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rien peut faire un micro
mais ça aurait pu être autre chose non
en revanche il faut parler dans le micro
il y a beaucoup de femmes qui peuvent se
reconnaître dans dans les rôles qu'elle
incarnent et peut-être trouver dans ces
personnages leur propre liberté en fait
c'est sympa ça vous avez vu les mots qui
reviennent talentueux évidemment mais
simple et accessible
ouais je fais bien semblant d'être cool
l'inverse je suis vraiment une merde en
fait je suis directeur de casting
et j'arrive vous posiez ce micro et que
vous jetez dans l'eau pour voir un peu
j'ai peut-être un rôle pour vous
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez alors ok ça
c'est dégueulasse mais moi Thomas il
faut pas me lancer comme ça OK
[Rires]
micro de télémata l'info le festival
continue demain d'ici là moi je retourne
au fort
comment ça il y a une nouvelle épreuve
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce qui va faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]